in several women request a brief
discussion of the Animas how can we
translate what men are saying about the
anima into our animus I think the best
thing is not to translate but to try to
experience it directly and I would say
how we experience how I rather say how I
experience the animus first before
knowing that there is such a thing as
the animus I just he was sure that I was
one person who had all sorts of holy
convictions and which I felt were
completely my own and also all sorts of
in my case sceptical thoughts about
distrustful thoughts about human beings
about reality about so on of which I
would have also said they are all really
my own and only when I entered analysis
I first recognized the animus in that
form that I dreamt about negative men
and positive men and you pointed out to
me that they personified so to speak
these thoughts in me and then I for the
first time it's who these realizing this
seeing these personifications in the
dream I began to wonder if these
different convictions and attitudes I
had where really mine if I if I would
want it really to identify with them and
furthermore I noticed that whenever I
identified with a certain of these
attitudes I got on the nerves of men not
only onions nerves but any man will do
as long as his reviled as long as he is
not effeminate then male automatically
bristle and that made me thoughtful and
then I
that showed me then the two things
together that generally when I had
identified with one of those personal
situations in my unconscious who
appeared personified in my dreams then I
got on on main snaps and if you put that
all together then you see that is about
empirically what the Animus amounts to
that's why young says it is absolutely
for a woman vitally important to have
relationships to the other sex for men
to to recognize the anima because it's
the simplest way of becoming aware that
the main are very friendly towards you
and open one has a nice conversation
suddenly because I was up in bristle and
then you must always ask yourself now
now what's wrong there am i not quite
myself in that moment now it can be that
one has also an insight of a conviction
of an attitude when is sure when one
author wants to do something and the
main bristle and it is not the Animus
because naturally may not do not only
dislike the animus in a woman but
sometimes also for certain reason
unknown reasons dislike something of her
genuine nature but it is not so frequent
but it can happen
I've often seen in when analyzing a
woman that sometimes she had to she
expressed to her husband her to in
herself feminine self and in spite of it
he having learned psychology say oh
you're in the Animus and so on when it
wasn't so there one can only recur to
one's dreams in such cases when the
dreams were confirmed to the woman that
she was on the right track and her
husband for some unknown reasons was
rejecting her from out of personal
complexes was rejecting whatever she
wanted to do or said or did but even
then the great danger is that if in such
a situation one then gets into the
Animas in other while in other way one
gets argumentative and and wants to
prove one's point and wants to press
once point
and I would say whenever I recognize
myself being in the Animus a when I get
on men's nerves
secondly when I can't let the thing go
when I kind of possessed when I can't
say well let's say three to differ let's
drop the discussion never mind when I
kind of get tricked into having to argue
the truths out that is always a symptom
of the animal being possessed by the
animals now you must think also that the
animus being that is describing more the
negative aspect of the animus but the
positive aspect is also there and then
it is the invitation from the
unconscious to from time to time act
like a man
which can form a woman be sometimes of
very great help
I remember that when I wanted to buy a
bit of land and had very little money I
had to give my last money to buy this
this bit of land and so after having
made the contract and everything ready I
I just got the G toes and I began to
imagine I'm not insured if I bough Kate
heel if I can't earn then I'm bankrupt
and you know the whole as well as in
sleepless nights and in that night I
dreamed that I was standing on the high
mountains of the valleys on one side of
the valleys Valley and which is about
200 kilometers broad and from the other
side from the long side I saw a black
speck coming through the air and I
looked in thought is that a bird it's
rather big for the bird and then he came
closer and closer and when he came after
about ten minutes
I began to see that it was a skier
a skier who jump who jumped 200
kilometers over the whole valleys here
would have run in Sapporo and
when he came close on you came through
the air and just land beside me with an
elegant Kristiania and I looked at him
in admiration and said oh my god how do
you do that
and there I saw he was a simple peasant
boy with a who grinned at me in a
friendly manner and say quite simple
chuck your eyes and jump now you see I
took they and I said to myself shut your
eyes and jump and just sign the contract
though I was shivering in my boots
now there I liked the Animus people
because I see me I mean it was an animus
act but I like it possessed me because I
thought this was a positive figure of me
and he was compensating my feminine
tendency to be anxious and afraid and
therefore I accepted the suggestion so
you see the animus can give a woman very
positive call it is we mustn't think of
the animals as something like only
negative Lunken it gives one the courage
to do things like that once feminine
nature trembles to do that it is again a
question as it was touched this morning
to discern the spirit who is who and and
to have it out with these inner figures
and to make up your mind I made up my
mind quite consciously now I'm going to
follow this peasant boy because I felt
he he was something in me which had this
kind of blind Nitra colored courage and
I felt this from looking at the figure
in the dream he was a kind of healthy
peasant and so I said yes to him and
incorporated him that was still animals
but so you that is the problem with the
animal see we have to but we should
never be identical
we should always know who it is apart
within oneself and then morally decide
yes or no and shall I let it act so me
or realize itself through me or shall I
in certain other situations say no this
is too much I knew I understood the
dream naturally I mean
as a compensation that I was in this
moment in a way negatively to feminine
to dependent
anxious not courageous enough to took a
lonely step and that that's about what I
would like to say about this question